قامت CNN بتقديم تقرير حديث للعقيد
ليتون عن أن الأوكرانيين يحرقون
الذخيرة بشكل أسرع مما يمكن للولايات المتحدة أن تقدمه
لأشياء مثل
نظام الصواريخ الموجهة المضادة للدبابات الرمح
ونظام الدفاع الجوي المحمول Stinger
وقذائف المدفعية ، ما هو نوع
الاختلاف الذي يحدث في
ساحة المعركة  أن الأوكرانيين
يحرقون هذه الأشياء بشكل أسرع من
الأمريكيين وحلفاء الناتو الذين يمكنهم
إرسالها هناك ، لذا فإن كل من Brian
و Stinger هما
سلاحان فعالان للغاية ولكن في اللحظة التي
يفقدون فيها هذه الأشياء في اللحظة التي
لا يستطيعون الوصول إليها  بعد الآن ، هذا
يعني أن الأوكرانيين بعد ذلك
أكثر مساواة مع الروس من حيث
القوة البشرية ومن حيث قدرتهم
على خوض الحرب فعليًا ، لذلك عندما
ترى مثل الرمح ، فإن
نظام الصواريخ الموجهة المضاد للدبابات فعال للغاية.
يمكن أن يكون لها
تأثير حقيقي حتى لو لم يكن لديك
دبابات ، فيمكن أن تقتل دبابات الجانب الآخر
عندما تذهب إلى صواريخ ستينغر ،
فلديك نظام مضاد للطائرات
يمكن لأي شخص حمله على
ظهره وإطلاق النار.  يمكن أن تقتل الكثير
من الطائرات ، ولكن إذا لم يكن لديك ذلك ، فلن تتمكن من فعل
ذلك وتفقد أي ميزة ،
فستحصل على هذا النحو ، حسنًا ، تحدث
عن ديناميكية أخرى في باك moot Wagner
الغربيين الذين يقولون إن فاجنر هو
القوة القتالية المرتزقة من  روسيا
تنفد من المجندين من سجون المدانين
لإلقاء القبض على
القوات الأوكرانية التي كانوا يخسرون فيها
عددًا هائلاً من الضحايا هناك في باكمان
وأماكن أخرى ، وهو الموقف الأخير لباك مووت واغنر ،
والسبب في ذلك
قد يكون لأنه مثلك تمامًا  قال
بريان إنهم يخسرون الكثير من
الأفراد ، فهم يخسرون الأسلحة التي
يستخدمونها من خلال الذخيرة تمامًا
مثل الأوكرانيين ومن
المحتمل جدًا أنهم في نهاية
خط الإمداد الخاص بهم من حيث  من
الأفراد ومن حيث الأسلحة